if you're worried about the spread of
the corona virus well you're obviously
not alone it's unsettling to see doctors
and what look like you know hazmat suits
in China and people quarantined hanging
out of hotel windows in Italy and of
course your fellow airline passengers
wearing face masks yet more unsettling
is something happening right here in the
United States and it's not medical it's
political Democrats in their media
cronies have decided to weaponize fear
and also weaponize suffering to improve
their chances against Trump in November
trump is incompetent we're seeing this
in coronavirus Donald Trump in general
not just with the coronavirus but in
general doesn't take important things
seriously they're scared to death about
the Trump administration has no idea of
what they do and four words describe the
administration's response to the
coronavirus towering and dangerous
incompetence well a few hours ago the
president his team gave us an important
update on how they're preparing for any
outbreak should they happen here the
number one priority from our standpoint
is the health and safety of the American
people the risk to the American people
remains very low we have the greatest
experts in the war really in the world
right here we're ready to adapt and
we're ready to do whatever we have to
as the disease spreads if it spreads the
Trump administration is going to
continue to be aggressively transparent
keeping the American people and the
media apprised of the situation and what
everyone can do all right perhaps I
could have done this a week ago but the
most important thing and the thing that
matters so Americans coast to coast is
that this effort is highly organized
extremely thorough and very well managed
but facts don't matter to the Trump
haters they learn from they never let a
crisis go to waste philosophy of Rahm
Emanuel that many of them are frankly so
sick with their anti Trump fever that
they actually consider this virus a
political godsend
finally they think they might have
something that may stick to trump
well let's face it they're really
frustrated right now these Democrats
think about it after Muller flopped
after the impeachment failed after they
constantly demonized Trump is a racist
sexist and every other issue you can
think of the economy and his approval
numbers continued to grow oh they know
how to do though is still panic what
else they really have at this point I
guess at Bernie's laundry list of
freebies free health care free pre-k
free college free medical care free
housing it's all a fraud no one takes
any of this seriously
remember when Reagan told us it's
morning in America and then Trump vowed
to make America great again and Obama he
offered hope and change
well the 20/20 Democrats on the other
hand are either hoping for misery or
actually peddling it none of the
candidates have an answer to Trump's
booming economy so they pretend as they
did in last night's debate that
Americans really aren't better off at
all we need a strong economy and to work
worldwide on that economy we all know
unchecked capitalism has failed you know
what but the ordinary American things
are not so good oh really Bernie well
even with the recent gyrations the stock
market every piece of economic data
shows that middle America is doing much
better than they did three years ago not
to mention that Americans are the
happiest they've been in decades and
that optimism is fueling more prosperity
just today we learned that the new home
sales number hit a 12-year high last
month but again remember good news for
you is bad news for the misery party if
you aren't sufficiently freaked out
about the corona virus you should
believe that at our core America we are
just a racist rotten country there is
racism in the criminal justice system
we've got to deal with instituting grace
unless President Iowa black my success
would have been a lot harder to achieve
I'm conscious of the fact that there's
seven white people on this stage talking
about racial justice I'm the only person
on this stage who believes in
reparations for slavery sometimes I wake
up and I think it's nine
1820 and on 2020 we have a criminal
justice system today that it's not only
broken it is racist just call them bad
news Bernie man it's a wonder after
listening to that marinate yourself in
that for a while it's a wonder that
millions have emigrated here from all
across the globe many of them people of
color why would they do that given how
the decks are apparently stacked against
all of them terrible rotten racist
country you'd have thought that the word
would have gotten around by now don't go
there they hate you it's all pretty
weird though don't you think that such a
racist society would see unemployment at
record lows for african-americans
Hispanic Americans Asian Americans
friends it's frankly just you think
about this all day it's just pathetic at
this point the Democrats are coming up
empty the great American comeback is a
fact and everyone who wants a job wants
to work is benefiting that's great news
and it's happening because the president
Trump's America first policies that
takes us back though to where we started
the Democrats latest desperate attempt
to gain the political upper hand when
nothing else is stuck when all else
fails argue that well we should just
spend more money this president has not
invested like he should have in his
budget he tried to cut back on the CDC
which was defunded Centers for Disease
Control CDC so we don't have the
organization we need we increase the
budget of the CDC we we increase the NIH
budget we should have right president
today and he's wiped out a lot out we
did it
Oh Joe actually the funding for the CDC
and NIH during the Trump administration
is higher than it was during the
obama-biden administration Congress has
been kept fully apprised of the crisis
with the first briefing held last month
when the president called all of this a
public health emergency and he imposed
travel restrictions on foreigners coming
in from China we should
working together she's trying to create
a panic Nancy Pelosi shouldn't and she
knows it's not true she knows it all all
they're trying to do is get a political
advantage
this isn't about political advantage
we're all trying to do the right thing
they shouldn't be saying this is
terrible president Trump isn't asking
for enough money how stupid a thing to
say well this is the time for calm
measured pragmatism not panic and not
political opportunism by a party that's
been buffeted by its own missteps and
failed strategies if they appear to be
rooting for Americans suffering and pain
during an election year I promise you
that the voters will put them in a
political quarantine come November and
that's the angle